just got a text from rob mcelhenny
saying that he's
walking in
well
the thing is uh we we agreed to meet at
8 30 in the morning we did say it was
gonna be an 8 30 start and uh and uh
we said 8 30. right it's 8 33 i was here
um i was here about
five off and i would have been had i
seen your cars and thought by the way
did you drive a different are you
driving i'm still i still i'm still
parking in the garage oh i was wondering
where you were parking i don't know i
like the then the car's not out in the
hot sun all day and uh you don't want
your car out in the hot sun i don't
well you know i mean buddy you got a
tesla you can you can you can tell
people what i have
i have a toyota corolla
i am a common man yes and you're keeping
it real yeah keeping it real
yeah so anyway we're here we're on time
this is the always uh sunny and
philadelphia podcast and i gotta say
do dude are you picking up on this i
feel like it's going a little bit better
without rob
you know what i uh
i feel like it's a little bit right now
it feels a little bit like that yeah
that's enough here he is oh well look at
that rob mcelhoney just rolls
whenever he wants to what time is it 8
36 is it it's 8 36 yeah yeah it seems
like it would be because we've been here
i've been here for uh
over six minutes and uh yeah first yeah
in the history of our relationship where
i was late my girlfriend or something
wow wow yeah we did say 8 30 did we not
boy there was a real specific uh text
chain like you know we're gonna start at
8 30. we'll go ahead and and uh make
sure you watch the episode beforehand
yeah i uh i watched that in the car on
the way here
i i did too
and you know what it is what are you
talking about it's really not safe well
yeah it's not safe what are you talking
i was eating my cereal and i was
watching the show and i was my car was
driving for me no i had it on i and uh
you know when i was at a stop light i
would i would like look down and watch
scene and otherwise i was just listening
to it kind of remembering which is
probably a little bit of a disservice
but there was no time there was no time
to watch the episode between the last
one what about last night you couldn't
watch it last night
today was the first day of [ __ ]
school and i was with my kids like i
didn't say today i was on last night i
was on daddy duty last night and then by
the time i got that kid down i was wiped
yeah um
didn't have it in you to watch 20
minutes if it's always philadelphia but
you're willing to do a podcast about it
buddy i ask other people to watch it i'm
not asking anyone to watch it i'm asking
them to listen to me talk about
something that they've already watched
that's so years ago
years ago and by the way listener we
have already established that charlie
day has a tesla sorry buddy how did you
mm-hmm rob's also got it i don't have
what
rob's also got a tesla right now you're
making now you're making stuff up well
charlie didn't want people to know that
he has a tesla he wanted people to think
he's driving a toyota corolla
because he's still jenny from the block
yeah that's right
charlie i mean i got a i got a pickup
truck i got a
right yeah an f-150 yeah that's what
i've got guys you know what's funny
disabilities
oh yeah let's talk about the episode i
thought it was great uh you know i
enjoyed it yes first of all i think the
the best way to watch our show is in a
car
[Music]
do you guys remember um
was it i don't remember if this is the
first time i mean rob you were the one
that actually went and uh pitched
the show to danny
uh you went alone you went to his house
and you pitched in the show
um that might actually be an interesting
story to tell but
i was gonna say
i i think the first time the three of us
actually sat down with him was that
lunch in beverly hills yeah right yeah
uh do you remember the name of the
restaurant it was an italian restaurant
it wasn't an italian place
it was on beverly boulevard there yeah
right near uh our management company's
office because that's where we were
riding the show that's right we didn't
have offices yet uh we hadn't figured
out that we could ask for something like
that um
[Music]
yeah and we sat down and we had we had
lunch and it was a very very strange
strange lunch uh danny was lovely um
but
he also uh would would go in and out of
character and we just didn't know and we
didn't know when he was we didn't know
when he was
i think there's something i picked up
but like these guys that
came up through that sort of 70s
hollywood into 80s hollywood
have a tendency to speak in
non-sequiturs right
which
which i think
was more accepted then because like
everything was like groovier so it was
like
everything was everything yeah like even
conversations were like a suggestion of
a conversation so it was like it was
like right man like you know like like
you know like oh man and all that and
then you know there's and then with the
oh the war and then all that and then
the other guy's like yeah no i dig it
man and so but like you know you you at
the time you were hanging out with
nicholson at the lakers game and he was
just talking gibberish to you oh wait
what's that story i don't know that
story this is the best this is let me
tell it for you because this is why i
love good charlie just wants to prove
that he remembers the story that's true
i remembered this thing
uh
this is what i love about rob but you i
i'm a sh i'm shy to the extent where i
won't i don't want to ruffle anyone's
feathers right yeah and
he here you're at a was danny at the
game oh yeah
that's why you and danny and jack are at
a lakers game well i didn't go with jack
i was with danny
yeah yeah nobody jack has a standing
invitation and so he's there and he
keeps turning to rob and he's spitting
like gibberish at you like give me some
examples of
yeah like first of all it's jack
nicholson so you're like oh this would
be cool but i don't know i don't want to
bother him but right you say something
clearly a basketball fan oh yeah and i
was there
enjoying the basketball game and he
he said something turned to me and i was
like oh he's going to talk to me this is
cool
and he said something like 45 half you
know and then back back back to the
quarter and that'll be 45
yeah there you go yeah and i was like
what
huh what man
and he's like i wish i remember the
exact phrase because it was in fact i
remember i texted it to you and right
after it happened and i was like this is
what the guy said to me it's in the
cloud somewhere yeah he's got to find it
i think uh that was six phones ago sure
yeah that's what i mean it's in some way
it exists somewhere you know the nsa is
looking at it they they've got it gates
he's got it gaitsy's got it he's all
over it that's this text now
sometime up in the uh
in the at the half court there
and i was like i don't maybe i can't
hear him correctly because it's loud and
i said i don't know what you're talking
about you said that to him yes and then
he just laughed and like
turned turned away and i was like well
jack nicholson everybody
i don't know what you're talking about
but i wanted but not in a i wanted to
engage with him yeah no no the way you
told it to me and i respected it more in
this version was you got eventually you
got frustrated and you were like look
man i don't know
what you're talking about yeah
you know which was the balls on you
to do that i would just again that's
that philly thing man or something he's
so insecure around him likely that i'm
just imagining that i would i would
respond to him i'd be like absolutely
man yeah
40 45
and then some 100 and can you believe it
right just trying to make something out
of it yeah i would take whatever i could
out of it and just go with the problem
but see this is the guy so i wanted to i
wanted to engage with him in a
meaningful way i would engage in just
the word i needed 45 abs 45 man
well this is the problem with uh with
somebody that is super super has been
super duper famous for a very long time
it is not required of them for from the
people that surround them yeah to make
sense right they can literally say and
do whatever the [ __ ] they want and
people will be like yeah yeah jack being
absolutely was a good introduce
introduction for us to that whereas like
sometimes he would say like a like uh
again a non-sequitur on the set and then
people like die laughing and we'd be
like what the [ __ ] is he what are you
talking about
but like now and again now laughing i
think that everything the guy says but i
do think that's a symptom of being
surrounded for so many years by people
that just laugh at whatever you say even
if it doesn't make any sense and isn't
funny at all because you're danny devito
and nobody wants to ruffle your feathers
and everybody wants to be in your good
graces so they're just like yeah they
didn't
you know they just laugh at your [ __ ]
nonsense and to the point where where
you just start to go like well i guess
everybody understands what's in my head
you just say whatever the [ __ ] is in
your head without the balloon it's like
you say but then there's also that 70s
thing man of like hey like there was a
lot of partying
and
uh life was loose conversations were
cocaine and and and to bring full circle
back to the conversation we had that
breakfast with him or lunch and it was
conversations like
my dad used to keep a box out of like
watches and teeth and you know it could
be like that and
a second i just want to clarify that is
you're not just making something up
right now that was the kind that's word
for work he was saying that his
grandfather
kept a box of watches as his father uh
his father i thought it was a girl okay
yeah either way a man in his life a man
yeah an important man in his life kept a
box of watches and teeth and was telling
us some kind of a story we were like
is he telling us a story as himself or
is he being frank right now it was very
hard for us to tell if he was in
character or a few like he might have
been in character that entire lunch and
i just did when we were like i don't
know but if you really can we speak with
daddy there can we speak with danny if
you look at it
the show did become about a [ __ ]
lunatic who would have a bunch of
watches and teeth in a box and he was
right he was spot-on yeah this is funny
to be talking to us like we're milos
foreman as opposed to three dudes making
a dick and ball comedy at lunch in the
middle of beverly hills yeah it's like
you don't have to do this [ __ ] with us
man like you know we're we're not we're
we're not at the actor's studio this is
the you don't have to be all [ __ ]
you can just come in and kind of say
you're like once we got him i went back
and watched every single danny devito
thing that i could because
i i wanted to be like what other ways is
he funny like we knew we were like all
right we're not gonna do like short
jokes it's lazy you know uh he doesn't
want us i mean he didn't say that but we
didn't want to be doing like that kind
of thing so like
what are some and well it was it was
like there was some obvious ways
right but there was a guy named
something short arms it was like it was
a teamster in in new york yeah that like
i remember i had him on the show third
watching he was driving me around so
yeah and he had like short arms so we
thought it'd be funny so when we were
doing the uh the
the gang or whatever the boxing episode
whatever the fighting episode boxing
episode is
called uh 100 baby
uh we
we we thought it'd be funny if uh
frank's nickname when he was a back when
he was young when he was a boxer was
frankie short arms
and he was we and we were pitching this
to him we were like you know so and you
were younger and you were like a boxer
you know when you were younger and you
had like a nickname like frankie's short
arms and he's like yeah yeah yeah yeah
not that though
and ever
ever since then like not that much has
become like a an ongoing phrase like you
know whenever somebody pitches something
that i think is not that funny
like yeah yeah yeah not that though um
having worked in a writer's room for so
many years specifically with you guys
and like you know
only 30 of the time you're actually
laughing it's maybe something i pitch
and then you're like oh okay that's good
but like 70 of the time you guys are
just like nah not that though or staring
at me or whatever and we all do that to
one another sure and then you know like
i i it's not a good
it's not a good feeling but it's like so
important to the process right so like
10 years the show's been on the air
and i remember being in a room a room
over at carousel and you guys for
whatever reason weren't there that
morning or something
and there was a room full of writers and
megan was there and i remember i pitched
something and the whole room like
erupted in laughter and i look and i'm
like oh okay i guess that goes on the
board and i look over at meg and she's
not laughing
and i just looked at her i said you
didn't find that was fun what do you
think meg and she was like
i guess i'm just wondering what it feels
like to have an entire room full of
people that you pay laugh at everything
you say oh [ __ ] oh damn you said that
yeah good for you
that was probably correct
get this girl out right right i know
she's a no girl she's a
29 year old 30 year old girl yeah uh no
but i i definitely remember like
laughing of course and then really
thinking about that quite a bit because
it's it's exactly what you're talking
about which is if you continue to
surround yourself with people a who you
hire right or b who just like
say yes or laugh at everything you say
then of course slowly but surely you're
gonna turn into that person that thinks
that everything they say is funny that's
right if you don't surround yourself
with people who check you yeah and tell
you hey man that's not funny it
shouldn't go on the show then your
shit's gonna suffer that's right i will
argue though with danny specifically
everything he says is [ __ ] funny like
uh but
but but like you got to learn to speak
because necessarily what he's saying is
funny but he has an essence because i
remember you know in that first season
for us it was a little confusing to be
like oh well you know he's jumbling some
of these lines in a way that like the
line doesn't make as much sense when he
does it in that order
and
we can't necessarily like and it will
you know it wasn't so egregious that
like we weren't getting through a scene
but be like oh he's kind of switching
that line up and it's not as funny but
like you watch it and you watch you go
back and you watch those episodes
it doesn't matter what he's saying yeah
in what order right like his spirit his
essence his attitude is so well
sometimes the jumbled up messed up
version of the line ends up what's up
being better yeah
this is a moment of appreciation for
danny devito doing the show because
that thing
that star quality thing and danny's not
like a star he's a superstar he's a mega
mega superstar he's iconic people love
him
the fact that this guy came onto the
show i still don't know it's crazy i
still don't know why it's crazy i i i
was having that like experience uh
watching and listening to the to the
episode this morning being like
he completely transformed this thing and
there i don't think there is a show
without him man like no no no no
definitely not my god like no there is
no show without him for sure that's my
appreciation for that for this guy
[Music]
well so i had a question for you guys
that's kind of related to that is
related to this episode have you guys
ever have either of you ever
uh pretended to be something
that you are not in order to get
something that you want like in a major
way like these characters
well i was gonna say besides pretending
to be a showrunner okay
okay i did used to dress up my friend as
dad had a um
one of those airplane landing lights
like that's like that cone light cool
and we found in his basement and he had
like a
uh like a like an orange like work coat
too down there
so
we i did used to rush laughing why are
we laughing i was just thinking about we
went down to the airfield and we were
taking planes down into the lake no we
didn't do that but we did go into an
intersection and direct traffic oh [ __ ]
that's really funny yeah yeah so that's
a good bit my friends were hiding in the
bush with the walkie-talkie and i and i
had the walkie-talkie in the airplane so
the car would come up and they would go
on the walk and talk like
that yeah
i should set the fan down there man you
can't go down that street like 14 years
old how old 14. i'm like
yeah like you can't go down that street
you're gonna have to take left here on
that vernon and you're gonna want to
head down the fender you can take it
right there
yeah one out of six and like that's
basically we would get like five or six
cars until someone would be like what is
this what are you doing okay and then
ultimately we would get that's a face
that's a funny goal to get chased do you
as a driver approach someone with a
walkie-talkie and one of those things a
vest and a light and a vest in the light
in the whole thing
and and the guy is trying to give you
you know tell you where to go with the
light and doing the whole thing but
you're like
but he's he looks like he's 14 years old
this can't be right like
there's no
sign of work or trouble or anything you
know but do you do it the 14 year old
says
um
80 of people do i bet yeah well yeah you
know now and 20 of them chase you
through the woods
which was the ultimate goal
i don't know if this falls into the same
category of what you ask but it falls
into the category of what charlie just
uh the story he told but we
i was like 16 or 17 maybe maybe younger
and i used to play this game uh which
was so cruel and terrible uh that we
call dead guys and it was
we would be at the jersey shore and
you'd wait till like sunset
and then you knew that people were just
sort of like walking down the beach and
so we would just roll in the surf as if
we were dead as if we were dead
like a dead body and so like and you'd
you know you could breathe but you'd
just kind of like flop around and then
the waves would like come up and crash
you and then people wouldn't know what
was going on but they saw and they would
be watching like what's happened did you
kind of have your eyes open a little bit
just a little bit just to get the
reaction
and then and then they'd come running
over like are you okay and then you just
get up and run away
and the last time we did it i was doing
it with my friend of mine dennis hogan
uh and
and it was a group of got like guys like
probably in their 20s and they they were
like oh my god are you okay and we were
like yeah and we ran into the water and
then we were like laughing and joking
and then we looked and they they were
standing on the beach
and they were just waiting and we were
like hey and they were like come on out
boys
and we were like oh no it was just a
joke and they were like yeah well it
wasn't funny to us we'll be here for you
and we were like these guys are going to
kick our ass yes they should hammer
which they absolutely should and so we
were like what the [ __ ] did we do so we
tried to swim like up and down the beach
but you can walk a lot faster than
someone yeah yeah so they would just
walk with us and and they and we just so
we just waited in the water for three
hours until finally they left and then
we we walked away in shame and never did
it again oh my god wow last time i
played dead guy i almost killed myself
well we didn't cover that we covered
that one yeah i did a similar thing with
my buddies like right when i got my
driver's license and i guess i was 16
and all my friends were younger and we
would drive around
doing bad things but um
i would pull up at an intersection and i
would pretend to pass out on the horn so
my head would be
and my friends would be panicking like
trying to revive me
and the people like because we want to
see the reaction of the the people in
the car next to us and they'd be looking
over most people didn't do anything
occasionally someone rolled down the
window like are you okay and then we
just like laugh and speed out of there
but it's just to be a dumb oh just to be
a dumb young little laugh just to get
all the guys out of life you know it's
harmless [ __ ] that made me think of a
really stupid prank that i that i used
to play over the okay so when uh when i
first moved to la um
[Music]
i
my parents had thankfully they hang they
hung on to my high school uh my
car that i got my senior year it was a
1990 acura legend pretty sweet
pretty sweet
and this car uh had um a
one of those giant brick you know car
phones in it those old school car phones
from like the early 90s so i had to go
pick up my car in montgomery alabama and
drive it out to la which is like a
three-day trip i mean you can do it
unless but i didn't want to kill myself
uh so this this this giant so i never
took that giant brick phone out of the
car because i just thought it was so
funny
um
so uh i'd be driving down the freeway
and just just in order to keep myself
amused and awake
i would do this thing where uh
i was dr i would i would be driving with
my knees
and i would have both hands i would have
the giant brick phone which by the way
at that point would have been a 15 year
old phone like you know we had nokias
and [ __ ] like that but
it looked ridiculous so i would pull up
next to somebody on the freeway i'd have
this giant brick phone in my hand and
with the other hand i'd be gesturing
wildly having a very furious
conversation with someone on this giant
brick phone
not paying attention to the road at all
completely not using my hands and i i
still to this day don't notice i don't
know if anybody actually ever noticed
that i was doing it but i i sure got a
kick out of it i thought it was funny
i'm hearing three stories of young men
who are desperate for attention
just desperate for anybody to pay
attention i was doing a bit i was doing
an acting bit yeah yeah yeah yeah you
just want people to pay attention
yeah yeah all stupid look at me
yeah look at my mom mm-hmm
dad
look at me friends like for me it was
with my it was all about my group of
friends like let let me make them laugh
i didn't even have anybody with me when
i was doing this stupid [ __ ] breath
like this was purely for my own
amusement
uh hoping someone will watch i stand by
it i stand by it i think it was a i
think it's a funny bit i think if you
look over and you see some guy with a
giant brick phone
and he's gesturing wildly with both of
his hands i i i think i think that
that's funny i think that's a good bit
too
thanks man i like that i appreciate it
that's been approved in my book
boy i also listened to uh the first two
harry potter books on that trip
so guys um
well you know it was a long trip wasn't
it
um
where were you guys
do you remember where were you
when season two got picked up and you
found out the news and what were your
feelings about it what what how did it
make you feel what did you think
where were you when you got the news
and how did you feel
i don't recall well i know where i was i
know exactly where i was when
danny
signed on to do the show okay because it
was minutes after i left his house he
called john and john called me and i was
like almost like on his street still
still and then i called you guys like
immediately so that i think that was
like why we got picked up right so as
soon as he signed on that was sort of it
and then it wasn't official yet but you
but at that point you knew it was like
that was what was required of us yes to
get
a somebody who could bring
eyeballs to the show yeah on the show
and we got
someone way better than we ever in a
million years could have thought we
would have gotten and he probably got
maybe 15 to 25 more eyeballs on the show
exactly yeah maybe maybe 30 more
eyeballs sure which is 15 people
that's a lot of people 15 people 30
eyeballs do you guys remember how much
of a hard time we had cutting that final
car crash where yes where you guys drive
yes totally because we didn't have a
stunt team there was no
there was but but but watch it so janky
i like it i was just so excited
to feel like oh
the the show i can see how the show
like took off from here
it doesn't mean we we got it right every
time but it feels like oh this this
feels like sunny and it also made me
excited about this podcast because i
think that that first season of the
podcast is a little rocky but i think
this is going to be the episode where we
really find our way although
last the first season's finale uh where
where mr steven spielberg came in well
that was just a huge guess that was a
great big gift for us yeah because yeah
i mean that was a like that was a danny
d devito level get yeah we got him in
season one
i mean that's pretty cool i have a
feeling he's gonna come back i think he
he told me later he had a good time he
said he had a good time
um well guys what
else i know a pretty good podcast pretty
good podcast should we talk about how
good the podcast was no definitely
should that be a segment where we no
oh god no well right now we're we're
shooting season uh 15 of the show
and uh 15. wow monumental
but i do think there was something good
about coming in and sh and doing a
podcast before we go film because i will
say
that often times like when we go to
write or whatever this is a time where
we
we joke around we talk we i feel like we
communicate best
nice we're not tired yet you know we're
not old and grumpy and tired right we
got our cold brew coffee we got our
coffee in us and and we're looking
forward to the potential of the day
hmm
is that what it is
i would say exactly
it might be for me
that i've now used all of my energy for
the podcast and have absolutely nothing
left for the filming of the show but it
doesn't matter because i get paid either
way this will be fun this will be fun
for the viewer then after you wat after
you listen to this podcast
go and watch the gang replaces d with a
monkey because that's what we're
watching that's what we're going to
about to show you see if glenn seems a
little low energy see if he seems a
little bit low energy you know what i'll
bring it i'll i'll bring you guys fine
okay yeah yeah i can fake it real good
now i i figured out how to do that i
honestly have not been
present
uh as an actor on this show for many
many years
uh have you been present
as a
human within your body
and your thoughts
ever you know there was this there were
a couple times where i did mushrooms
uh-huh and then and then you arrive and
then you're like okay i was like oh here
it is yeah okay here it here i am yeah
and then the rest of the time i'm you
know it's like you're you're doing
whatever it is that you're doing but
you're already thinking about like
what's what's for dinner and like i
think it'd be very very good in today's
scenes because it's you know it's a lot
of like uh just us in the bar
oh boy i got a lot we have a lot of
dialogue today guys we got a lot of
there's a lot of talkie talkie we do we
do but a lot of talkie talking it's not
talking walkie so like you know we'll
we'll it's it's real it's real simple
stuff we'll just be in no walking into
all right after walking and talking not
proppy you know we're just kind of
sitting and talking it's well there's
gonna be an imaginary monkey in the room
all day no a real monkey no a real
monkey right now all right sorry
that's sort of season one thing
well guys this has been fun i'll see you
on set roger did you work out this
morning no i
i i had some some crazy dreams i was up
all night from about two to about 4 30
and then i fell back asleep what were
you dreaming about back asleep were you
dreaming about it it was it was it was
dark stuff
dark stuff not for this podcast were you
dreaming you had coven
no did you kill did you kill anybody did
you kill me
no i have a recurring nightmare that's
in that space not you um but where you
kill you've marked well yeah it's
happened in the past
but there's no reviving with it is that
i i think is that like imposter syndrome
like you know to the max where you're
like okay i'm a fraud and and and i'm
getting away with something i shouldn't
be getting away with i'm gonna get
called out on i think it's feeling good
it's definitely feeling guilty about
having done something to someone in the
past
and
uh
you know but trying to forget about it
but not being able to live with do you
think it's that in my in my in my own
research with
therapists over the years it's actually
been the the former
where it's been
the suggestion
there's no actual violence that happens
and that there is no uh there is no like
actual victim it's just someone who's
been
that i've killed and the story that's
being told is that the cops are after me
and there's a cop one in particular
who's like i know it was you and i'm
gonna i'm gonna well but that's what i'm
talking about you murdered i don't mean
that you didn't you're a cop woman
no that was like that was so interesting
really interesting no stop stop
but you know i think there's a fear of
that you're to lose it all right like if
you're going to be arrested you're going
to lose it all so probably in your life
you know you've accomplished these
things you have this wonderful family
that's what you did
you murdered your career and you have
this this great career and you have this
underlying fear well i'm just you know
who am i i'm not a writer i'm not an
actor i'm just i'm just robbed so like
i'm a big phony and it could all be
taken away from me i am here as your
friend to tell you that that is true um
yeah and and the sooner you accept that
and just let it go and be like yeah i'm
a big fraud but so is everyone else just
ask stephen stephen doesn't know what
he's doing steven just each movie is
potential disaster steven
who just stepped in the room yeah what's
up guys
what what what are we talking about well
rob has imposter syndrome and i say
don't fight it and say oh i'm a great
creator that's [ __ ] be like yeah i'm
a fraud so what so everyone's a fraud
make it till you make it baby
you nobody's nobody is what they are
until they do what they do and then once
you do it then you are what you are
whether you are or aren't
but
you know basically what i'm saying is
that nobody like you said nobody really
knows what they're doing so you just
have to do it
you just have to do it yeah yeah that's
the thing and you got to be decisive
you'll get that's the thing that you run
into a lot of times with the directors
where it doesn't work
whether you're right or wrong doesn't
matter you have to right because you're
going to get down to set the shark's not
going to work and then you got to make
choices right yeah yeah you know like
you
could be planning on seeing that shark a
lot suddenly you're like you know what
we're gonna have to make this where you
don't see the shark a lot and then
that's a lucky thing because then
suddenly you're like this movie's better
because i'm not seeing the shark as much
as i'm supposed to see in the first
place so shut up about your dreams rob
all right i see you again yes he's steve
this has been fun all right
i'll see you on set yeah we'll stay on
set see you on set